the Joe Rogan experience well we just
did an hour sir
so I'm gonna let you go because I know
you got very important things to do one
last question if you got into the office
and you found out something about aliens
if you found out something about UFOs
would you let us know I'll tell you my
wife would demand that I let you know is
your wife a UFO not knock she's letting
UFOs know it says birdy what is going on
you already access the records you don't
have any access okay you let us know
though all right I'll be on the ship
well doubts about the show how these all
right you guys thank you sir I
appreciate your time oh thank you very
very much